we have a voicemail number which you can
call any time
that the mood strikes that number is
2192
david p here's a caller asking
okay okay okay maybe trump is not likely
to delay the election but
if he does who becomes president it's a
good question take a listen
david hi i just wanted to call and
give you a little bit of a correction on
something you said
last week when you were talking about
trump's insane tweet about
delaying the election you said that uh
if the situation were that we didn't
have an election by january 20th
um that nancy pelosi would become
the president united states because
trump's terminal expire obviously mike
pence's term would expire
um that first part is right their terms
expire but
the second part is not actually nancy
pelosi will also be on the ballot
and her term expires a little earlier in
january if there's no election
so she the entire house would basically
be
empty if there were no election and so
nancy pelosi would actually not be the
president united states the president
states would be
whose third in line which would be the
president approach tem of the senate
86 year old after actually 87 when he
by that time chuck grassley so
that will be chuck rashly president
an entire house that is completely
vacant and a senate that is a third
vacant base
so there's actually it's actually even
more complicated than this so first of
all
it is conceivable imagine that so
the election is really 50 elections
right each state
runs an election it doesn't appear as
though trump can just delay the election
from the federal level but he could ask
governors to delay state elections
it could happen that enough state
elections are delayed
such that there's no winner in the
presidential race
but california might have their election
and nancy pelosi
could win so it's actually from what i'm
reading conceivable
that you might not have enough states
running elections to have anybody get to
270 electoral votes
but if california did their election
it's theoretically possible that nancy
pelosi would
be elected to another term but let's
actually play let's imagine
that the house is vacant okay it would
not be chuck grassley what would happen
from my understanding and i went over it
with producer pat today a couple of
times
um there are a bunch of senators who are
up for re-election
and it's two it's one-third of the
senate
they would all those 35 seats would all
be vacant so you would have 65
senators left because republicans have
way more seats to defend right now than
democrats
the 35 seats that would be open would be
mostly republican seats
this would put the senate back in
democratic control
at which point they would vote on who
becomes senate pro tem
and usually they go with the most senior
senator which would be vermont senator
patrick leahy so so it's actually
even more complicated if the election
were delayed
and nobody there were no no elections at
all
the senate elections don't happen that
leaves 35 senate seats vacant the house
is vacant
okay the remaining 65 senators who are
more democrats than republicans
vote on a new senate pro tem who becomes
president
by history that would be patrick leahy
knowing that the person would become
president maybe they would vote for
someone who's younger than patrick leahy
i don't know
but it's like two layers more
complicated even than that
and hopefully it doesn't come to this i
don't believe that it will i believe we
will have
a presidential election we have a great
bonus show for you today we are going to
talk about the new republican-backed
heels act we'll talk about what's going
on in the nba
we will talk about canadians sneaking
i'm sorry americans sneaking into canada
in boats yes we are now the ones doing
that
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show